the unknown that awaits us in the future
can be unsettling we're living in an era
where our conditions capabilities and
understandings are progressing so fast
and in so many different directions
anything is possible and essentially a
blink of the eye the entire world can
change with the way things are going
right now it can be easy to lose hope
and become scared for humanity's future
but what use is this if the future is
uncertain Watchers fear over hope Wonder
and excitement the things that await us
may be good or may be bad but all we can
do is hope and strive for the best and
so with this in mind let's consider and
imagine for a moment what in fact that
could be the following is a potential
ideal rendering of the future based on
current trends and predictions is
arguably just as possible as it is not
it is a future that could very well
become real while you are still alive
all it takes is one new little piece to
tip an entire scale of reality now put
yourself in the shoes of your future
self and imagine this it is some amount
of time in the future you're planning
out a vacation with some friends and
family you're deciding which location
you would like to visit in our solar
system similar to how you would a cruise
ship you are picking which space travel
line you would like to go on as well as
what destinations you would like to stop
at like tropical islands there are
planets that you can travel to where
there are societies with economies
thriving on tourism research and
resource mining not only that but these
new other planetary settlements have
allowed for the discovery of new sources
of nutrients fuel and elements that are
now integrated into our everyday lives
the massive practical value provided by
these new resources means that the
issues created by things like fuel
emissions and power requirements here on
earth have been resolved what was once
known as global warming is now a lesson
taught in history classes with greater
resources and limited energy
restrictions the rate of technological
advancement has continued to compound
while the concern of artificial
intelligence becoming uncontrollable has
been properly dealt with government
program specializing in the research
understanding and regulation of AI have
been implemented like any other
potentially threatening technology or
weaponry the proper regulations were put
in place before it was too late
ái now integrates cohesively into human
life in an increasingly symbiotic
relationship
it has freed up much of the waste of
time in researching and understanding
complex issues it has allowed us to
answer questions we never thought to
even ask to innovate in directions we
never knew existed to live in ways we
never thought were possible at any given
moment new worlds of opportunity and
understanding are uncovered life is
never boring there's so much to do
explore and discover furthermore
technological automation has increased
so much the humans no longer work
trivial or laborious jobs these jobs
have since been replaced with new jobs
that cater to a more ideal level of
human skill set capability and interest
work is now dependent on thinking
imaginatively
and innovatively rather than feeling
depressed or imprisoned by work you and
everyone you will know from this moment
forward experiences work as a means to
an exciting life and a chance to connect
with themselves as well as the
collective education has been
restructured to attend to this shift
school is no longer based on
memorization of rigidly standardized
curriculums instead it is open diverse
and practical to human life it covers a
greater range of topics and adopts
emotional intelligence mental health
career selection and financial literacy
as some of the new primary focuses in
addition to traditional subjects moving
forward all children will be properly
equipped to utilize their intelligence
in the most effective and rewarding ways
racism sexism and other minority
prejudices are no longer tangible
opportunity wealth and success are no
longer predicated by family heritage or
appearance but based on who people are
as individuals and what they can do
objectively those previously in poverty
or underdeveloped societies are now in
comfort and affluence more opportunities
for more people means more smart people
and more smart people means more
innovations and discoveries which means
more people have been working on solving
major problems while advancing
technology works in parallel to execute
the solutions from a medical perspective
a newfound comprehensive understanding
of the human genome now allows us to
quickly eradicate diseases as well as
ensure that newborn humans are born with
optimal health the relationship between
human understanding and technological
innovation has become so interwoven
evolution is now spilling over into new
dimensions of interplanetary Bionic life
evolution is compounding at a 10 X
multiple 10 years is like 100 100 years
is like a thousand and so on this
alongside developing anti-aging medical
treatments means you are aging at a
dramatically reduced rate proportional
to time because by the way your whatever
age you are right now plus about a
hundred give or take currently you're on
track to live a longer healthier life
than any conceivable age of the past as
a result you will experience the most
diverse dynamic and unique existence
ever known to human you and nearly
everyone you know are happy with life
and it is not corny or weird to feel
that way for the first time known in
history the entire body of humanity is
functioning together cohesively like one
big super machine there is an
underlining attitude that when everyone
wins the individual wins violence and
war is minimized in empathy and kindness
grow stronger and stronger longer
lifetimes creator understandings of the
universe and our role within it and more
time to focus on self-care and
meaningful work all allow for a greater
sense of self purpose we now recognize
that life is simply what you make of it
that our purpose is merely to enjoy
everything as best we can while
providing as much honest value to others
along the way so to ensure that everyone
can do the same life is beautiful
humanity is happy any conceivable heaven
would fall short of this ok now back to
the present that future just described
is certainly optimistic but between now
and then anything could happen
and if even a sliver of any of that
comes to fruition imagine the
possibility the mere idea of the
possibility is enrapturing perhaps some
of it may seem far-fetched and perhaps
some of it is because of course we took
some creative Liberty here but if you
were to write down everything you did
and encounter today and then could send
it back 50 years in the past I believe
that whoever would read it would have
the same skepticism about today's
conditions and if this is true and some
150 years ago would have been as
skeptical and as excited about our car
in 2018 conditions imagine how surprised
you are going to be in one
there's a lot to be excited about and a
lot to be hopeful for literally right
now is like science fiction let alone
fifty or a hundred years in the future
so enjoy yourself and believe in
humanity any alternative is useless
[Music]
thank you for watching if he found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder